aujourd'hui la cuisine des mousquetaires
et bien ça ne sera pas cette cuisine
somptueuse à laquelle maïté vous aviez
habitués pas de foie gras pas de
sangliers pas de grievous bécassine pas
d'ortolans mais enfin vérité on va faire
quand même une cuisine car ce que nous
lui zine de chez nous quand même offert
la soupe et bien tous les menus commence
je mange de la soupe tous les soirs oui
ah oui oui c'est bien servait la soupe
c'est très simple c'est très bon les
mousquetaires pang manger et la soukra
servent aujourd'hui quelqu'un fût gas
corp laisse tout comme il en a plein qui
sont des sources gascogne et bien les
mousquetaires dont sûrement bon il ya la
soupe à l'ail gang la clé ici notre tour
a blanchi le tour et blanc justement à
faire d'abord le tour a blanchi ensuite
oui nous faisons la soupe aux vins
soudain c'est aussi bien de la région et
ensuite pour finir nous ferons la soupe
de femmes de rabbins qui n'est pas bien
connue mais qui est absolument exquise
alors on commence donc par le tour
pendant 7 vous ce tour c'est très facile
s'est très vite fait surtout on prend de
l'aïe
on parlait on le coupe en deux pour
toujours enlever le germe et pourquoi
est-ce que vous enverrez un déplacement
au niger plus facilement
et puis on lâche alors vous le hacher
asseoir en parla choix on écrase alors
que nous qu'est ce que vous allez faire
et finir de vous lâcher
qu'est ce que vous allez faire pendant
ce temps alors je prends et le poil je
mets de la grèce et je vais mettre dès
que la poêle sera chaude
je vais mettre mon ait agi film est
finement il faut que ce soit bien son dû
avant ou pas oui un petit peu parce que
là il ne faut pas qu'ils cuisent 40 min
qui brandissent les lieux
vous allez voir qu'est ce qui se passe
que si tu sais trop en ont ils été
marnaise l'ail et où il y devient marron
très vite
vous savez il a la puissance de l'art
est passé c'est dingue ou brûler ces
thèmes cramer commune vi et ses parents
bon alors à notre envie notre crès elle
chauffe
on va mettre notre aïn voilà on va le
faire et fait râler c'est quand même de
résilier de titres et poèmes mais on
remue un peu surtout pas qu'ils prennent
et il faut surtout pas qu'ils non non
non non non non c'est encourageant cela
nous avons une casserole d'eau
on va y mettre du sel bien sûr voilà du
sel du pouvoir que je vais vous apporter
une forme attaques armées
la preuve il faut que ça s'arrête parce
qu'il ya de l'eau du sel du pur à 20
alors le poivron prendre ou l'air parce
que si on le move
au dernier moment il a plus de saveur
c'est comme le café savoir la au dernier
moment on a la chance ici d'avoir un
vieux moulin alors c'est plus joli ses
meilleures hausses voyez là il commence
à fait sont un tout petit peu alors on
va le raimu et oui bien sûr peut
patrouiller le regard de l'auteur marcel
déjà ça sans rien et c'est ça qui donne
le bon bout la preuve est là
evreux n'a pas le rêve doré appel de
l'arrêt peine de remplacer taille avec
la grèce en mai dans la bouillante et
elle arrive à les laisser combien de
temps vous alors là je vais changer la
fois parce que l'envoyé ça vous passez
vite et alors je vais remettre gras
dessus sur ce gaz non pour que ça vaut
plus vite je vais faire ma place
on va laisser bouillir 5 5 minutes 5 10
minutes
et qu'est ce qu'on va faire pendant ce
temps pendant ce temps je vais prendre
une assiette que voici
je prends une assiette je prends de19
alors pour cette activité il me faut de
vieux alors je vais me reprendre et
l'entretien je vais mettre ma le blanc
d'oeuf dont sur lequel je sais par le
blancs des jaunes qu'elle attendait la
wii
allez y ajoutant mais de jean le duff
oui je prends une fourchette jeu bat c
alors que rien n'a que deux ça ne se
passe pas facilement quand y est c il
faut étudier la chose je vais prendre de
l'eau tout simplement de lui un petit
peu d'eau j'en ai pas je vais pas mettre
beaucoup et que ramasser quoi voilà
voilà c'est ça rien d'absolu c'est pour
nous battre plus facilement qui a oui
c'est ça pour le voir traverser la voie
il regardait déjà très bien tenu à ça
c'est un peu plus léger mais si je le
bats rien pour bien suivre tout le monde
jeunes comme si vous allez faire une
raison oui pareil comparer y voilà
et alors là je vais prendre du vinaigre
et pour que des neiges pour donner un
petit peu j'étais un petit peu de huy de
pékin à la soupe
ouais ayéva ce panneau pour pas il
faudrait que ça tombe bien je prends un
peu de vinaigre je mets un sou plus la
valeur d'une grille est à la source de
bonne cuisine du bourg il joue depuis
hier on continue à battre pour ma soupe
bout voilà alors maintenant je vais
prendre ma mon assiette avec mais ce je
vais retirer la casserole du feu et je
vais m
mais eux non vinaigre alors je vous fais
une cuillère je vais remuer pas ce qu'il
faut faire à face aux violettes
voilà il faut que ce soit bien blanc
qu'est ce que ça peut sentir baudic
incroyable
le père françois olivier dupin et on
coupe
voilà des tranches de pain comme ça et
qui croûtons des flics le nom de perle
alors si celui qui aime vraiment live
pour repasser ses croûtons à l'ail
mais je pense que ce n'est pas
nécessaire il y en a qui le nomme pas
moi je le fais tu as toujours là voilà
et maintenant va verser 2,6 la suite
tout simplement alors par la soupe
l'assiette la louche la lauch bien sûr
on va jusqu'au fond et on va là bas elle
reprit pinson raconte dans des vieux
livres mighty comportait cette soupe ou
marié la chambre des noms s'égrènent
bien sûr bien sûr bien pourquoi ça leur
donnera vertus me raconter autre chose à
moi a veillé tout autre chose qu'est-ce
que vous n'avez pas deviné vouloir
donner un petit peu de vigueur un peu de
vigueur voilà jeunes aux jeunes mariés
et bien voilà maintenant qu'ils vous
aient séduit pour donner de la vigueur à
ceux qui ont regardé aux jeunes mariés
le tour à blandas harraga et maintenant
la philosophe à ce qu'on veut alors nous
allons essayer de faire une soupe aux
1,8 ou alors maïté comment allez-vous
lafleur oui alors on prend une part en
très chaude à rentrer cheyrou les au
flop
en fait cela est excellent c'est ce
qu'on appelle à paris du la douleur mais
c'est vous c'est d'avoir oui on nous
coupe un petit carré comme ceux ci on
prendre des petits oignons qu'on coupe
pareille on écoute comme ça et pour les
aînés au sein même prendre tout ça on le
met dans une poêle alors qu'on gagner du
temps sait déjà qu'on l'a fait s'est
désolée mais qu'est-ce que vous avez mis
dans votre poêle avant de la grèce vrai
donc je vous l'internet grâce 1.13 de
canard une bonne cuillère à soupe
ensuite les lardons gélard dans les
zones ue et tous à revenir à petit feu
dans l'est mais pas brûler exactement
et ensuite on prend de la farine enfin
dans la farine aux poudres
les prisonniers ont deux papas pas
énormément voilà c'est tout pour le tout
voyez qu'est ce que ça fait j'aurais
fait les mêmes oui là offrant une
casserole qui est à côté de nous en a
mais sur le feu et on vide le tout dans
cette casserole je vais vous dire qu
après je monte un tout petit peu le gas
que voilà et je parie que vous allez
arrosé de vin versé 10 nuits alors vous
m'avez dit enfin bien corsé on va bien
corsé de bison par exemple et bien
saint-émilion très corsé ou peut-être à
pomerol c'est ce qu'une combinant c'est
encore mieux dans ce cas mieux c'est
suivant les moyens et plus le vérin et
vent et corps est meilleure et de tovè
en vide
ce verbe dans l'oignon les shadows union
l'ardèche et notre grèce on y met le
trois-quarts
oui voilà un endroit car on laisse
bouillir est alors en attendant a animé
deux branches de laurier parce qu'il est
bien jolie oui voilà et puis un peu de
terre un peu de thym rien à ces voix là
en salle et on peut enfin je vous passe
la relation site la wii dans notre petit
muller
on y met le sel le poivre et on s ouvrir
bon alors ça va bouillir à peu près
combien une vingtaine de minutes on a
tous des messages de minutes parce qu'il
faut bien que le ter le laurier et
prennent de goût on a ce bouillir une
vingtaine de minutes
et quand c
sa bouillie il est question de race est
entre temps peut-être préparer quelque
chose entre temps nous allons ne sommes
que vous m'avez parlé de ckoi lieu
d'ailleurs de pommes de douala parce
qu'il faut le mettre à l'an dernier
alors en plus nos pommes de terre avec
une assiette et le rap
alors on prend la pomme de terre et ont
rappelé cette bande de terre comme ça ça
fait ça va lier dans les pommes de terre
sont rap et on va les mettre
ici nous avons notre verne
il faut on prend les pommes de terre on
les met dans la casserole en revue on va
s'ouvrir un quart d'heure c'est quand
même un calvaire tout un quart d'heure
le tout voilà puis au bout d'un quart
d'heure rick on verse la soupe en verre
sur la soupe dans l'assiette
voilà la soupe thibault voyez comme les
ligues et les communes et bien oui ça
fait un peu comme de la sécu ont presque
fait avec comme c'est râpé très très fin
avec un promoteur voilà hills a pris une
bonne excuse ron voir si la soupe aux
verts la soupe aux vingt deux
agriculteurs et les couleurs voilà nous
la posons sur la taille la tap
voilà et pillent tout est là un peu
pendant que prépare la soupçonne de
xabier après prenez la loupe ce jeune
personne
par la paix douter luz a brûlé par le
son ça s'entend
[Musique]
et mme solis est bon c'est beau hein
mais c est bien la prochaine maintenant
la soupe de fun de radis on y va on y va
c'est le potage le plus économique
quand vous achetez un paquet de radis
vous coupez les fans bas tout le monde
jette d'habitude non alors là il faut
pas jeter vous coupez les fans bon et
quand vous faites un bouillon vous
faites un bon bouillon bouillonne trop 3
2 3 via berne via le bouilleur bien
corsé vous mettez dans ce bouillon des
pommes de terre que vous coupez un petit
carré là un petit morceau comme ça vous
les mettez dans ce bouillon et vous
prenez vos fans également que vous
mettez dans ce bouillon pour nous on a
déjà fait pour gagner du temps
on prend ce circuit une assiette à faire
demain dans l'assiette c'est moins
facile on va mettre là dessus le pré ce
pur et au pétrole
le légume
voyez les fans et les pommes de terre et
on fait tourner qui ont cuit à peu près
encore un quart d'heure les pommes de
terre sont cuites f-16 vinyle et sel et
du poivre et sel et le bouillon et très
corsé cet avion avec du boeuf du veau et
du port du poireau des carottes des
navets voilà donc on ne recèle pas un
ras le bol de lire les mots inter bon se
fit est passé voyez vous oui et on met
dans le bouillon les fanes de radis
casser les répondeurs dans ce bon
bouillon et qu'est ce que vous êtes en
terminale et après on le lit avec de la
crème fraîche 1 et bien voilà la crème
fraîche et c'est tout et on le sert
immédiatement ordre serré médiateur nous
ayons tous shoah oui voilà allez mettez
nous a compliqué oui c'est une bonne
soupe à l'aller on dit que gascon et
donc son souffle avec des fanes de radis
mais les romains la faisait avec des
orties des orties est la même avec
avec les antilles c'est presque meilleur
avec les orties et sans jouer toujours
essayer c'est la même recette
alors voilà c'est qu'aux femmes d'ovalie
le tour un blanc et la soupe aux vingt
trois bonnes soupes intrigues de chez
nous et avec cela
au revoir et à bientôt
[Musique]